hey guys my name is Jess it is a 16th of
febri and here's some news that is
primarily related to gaming please reply
to another outlet for all the social and
political on going in a completely
unexpected turn of events Rafa Lupe
Fiasco defeated iconic professional
fighting game player Daigo Umehara in a
street fighter 5 exhibition match the
match was initially proposed to be Oscar
over Twitter by mark mark man Julio the
former community and sponsorship manager
for peripheral company mad catz in
preparation for the match Lupe Fiasco
said he was training and going over
strategies and drills which seriously
seemed to have paid off Fiasco who chose
to play Ken ended up winning out over
umehara Sri you after a very close set
that ended up scoring 32 next up the
lead writer on Mass Effect Andromeda has
left to buy or where to go join death to
me develop a bungee Chris laughs who was
also previously the lead writer for Halo
4 at 343 industries confirmed on Twitter
that he has officially left Bioware
after two years he wrote I am no longer
working on Mass Effect Andromeda at
Bioware Montreal sincerely one of the
best experiences of my career I'm
incredibly grateful to have worked with
such talented and truly wonderful human
beings think about Effect Andromeda is
really going to blow people away
couldn't be prouder to be a part of it
and excited like a little kid to play
the final when it's out he added that he
thinks Bungie has some interesting
stories to tell on top of that his
linkedin profile gives a hint of what
will be getting in the next Mass Effect
game as one of his duties includes
expansion of traditional Bioware
storytelling tools and techniques into
new areas leveraging increased player
choice and agency in world narrative and
asynchronous storytelling Andromeda is
due out in force 2016 for pace a ps4 and
Xbox one
finally the pullout for expansions have
been announced detailed and repress the
first expansion is called a tomar on a
two-out in March and individually priced
at ten bucks in this adventure a
character called the mechanist releases
a bunch of evil robots into boston thing
to deal with one of which is the quote
devious Robo brain once you kill them
off you can use their parts to build
your own robots by mixing and matching
limbs as you please in April the
five-dollar wasteland workshop arrives
which lets you design and set cages to
capture things ranging from Raiders to
death claws apparently you can tame them
and have them fight each other so you
can settle the age-old debate of who
would win between a death floor and a
glowing red scorpion the expansion will
also include a bunch of new settlement
design options third and finally for
Harbor will launch in May this $25
expansion will ask you to take on a
mission from Valentine's detective
agency to find a young woman and a
secret colony of since set off the coast
of Maine and likely replicating the
popular tourist location Bar Harbor far
Harbor is slated to be the largest piece
of content of Bethesda has ever created
for an expansion it's also set to offer
up a whole lot of new higher level armor
and weaponry more content which is yet
to be detailed will arrive later in 2016
and Bethesda are also promising more
features and updates including a
survival mode overhaul and various
optimizations the publisher have said
that given their offering up more DLC
than they planned their kicking up the
DLC pass price wire whopping 20 bucks
that said if you buy the season pass
before march one you can pay the
original price of thirty dollars closed
betas for the expansions will be held
closer to their release dates and you
can sign up through to Thursday's
website let me know down in that comment
section how you feel about these
expansions and their pricing you can add
to gamespot we've got stories on Dark
Souls 3 DLC and the Knights of the Old
Republic remake that is everything I
happy today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I will see again
mar